Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Freddy Fazbear's Pizzeria Simulator.
Now, we've got a lovely place here, but before we do anything, I'm gonna put safety straps on that fruit punch-
guy--
and I'm gonna play test him
[music]
Surprise as many kids as you can!
[air horns]
[odd mechanized voice] "Fruit Punch for Everyone"
I don't wanna surprise anybody... I don't want that, that sounds awful...
I don't wanna surprise anyyyboooddyyy.... (x2)
[air horns]
[mechanized voice, pronouncing words incorrectly] "Lemonade for Everyone" (yes that was English)
What did you say?
Uhh....Okay, you know what? I'm gonna try.... the hoops again
[arcade game music]
Heyyy Ayy!!! I got 20! Hell yeah!
HEYYYY!!!! OOOOH!!!! WOAHHHH!!!
All right! Cool! I'm gonna save my money.
I'm gonna need them for the lawsuits that are definitely coming with Lefty up there.
I shouldn't have Lefty there. I'm gonna have Lefty there.
The lawsuits are [laughing] hilarious.
Which is a terrible thing to say, but the lawsuits are, in fact, hilarious!
I'm gonna hire a handyman, that, okay. All right, here we go. Here we go, place those bulbs, baby
Handyman, get out there! You're doomed, but get out there
[fan turns off]
Okay...
Easy-- [interrupted by an ad] Ahhhhhhh... Thank you for that, no, no, that's--
I'm gonna die. I'm gonna die immediately-- I'm gonna die
I'M GONNA DIE!!
[fan turns off]
[another ad plays again]
[screams] AHHH, WACKY WART, NOOO!
[Baby jumpscare] No! Ahhhh!
Baby: "You're not who I expected to see."
You're not who I expected to see either, Baby! Going back into it...
[Mark laughs, but soon it morphs into crying]
All right...This game is, uh... scawy. I should, I should just...
should just use all my play tokens shouldn't I? Okay.. I might do that
[arcade music]
uh oh (x4) ahhhhhhh
[spine cracking on impact]
Ill-fated, I suppose.
Nope! UHH-- AWWW
[spine cracking on impact]
Uh oh, here we go-- Aaah not this again!
[spine cracking on impact] [laughing while crying]      This poor baby bear [aka, Helpy]
Yup, I did it again! I did it-- ahh, ahh, I-- oh
Poor baby bear! Poor baby bear... I was just off-sync the whole time
No, don't give me those. I don't feel like I deserve those- All right, great. I'm gonna
I'm gonna go. I'm gonna go now go I'm a-goin die
again
aye yai yai
[ad starts playing] Nope! Not what I wanted, Flossy!
[ventilation turns off]
Hi, welcome to Hell. I can't get away from you, can I?
[slight squeal] No, I don't like--
Dilapidated Springtrap: You may not recognise me at first, but I assure you, it's still me.
Come on man man, maaaaan
Man
C'mon man
Oh jeez
[ad starts playing] Aw c'mon, Wacky Wart Paste-- I wish I'd never taken any of you
[Molten Freddy jumpscare] Ah!
Molten Freddy: "One big, happy family!"
Excellent. Okay, this is getting ridiculously difficult. Hmm...
I'm dead. I'm just dead.
[Lefty Jumpscare] OHHHHH, LEFTY! LEFTY!
Lefty, quietly: Shh...
Lefty!! Lefty, you bastard! Lefty, come on!
You sack of shit, Lefty! I knew I couldn't trust you. I knew I couldn't trust you Lefty-- Goddamn it. (When will you learn)
Wow, this is the jump-scare episode, huh?
It was just the episode of death- Oh God, why?
Why? Why is any of this?
[Molten Freddy Jumpscare] AH! I don't know how to beat you!
I don't know. I do not know.
Maybe the risk is also on my part. Maybe that's also part of the risk
All right, maybe I gotta alleviate a little bit of risk.
You know, maybe I got to tone it down a bit because the risk seems to be extremely high- and I'm extremely dying
Okay, let's- let's tone this down. Good old Lefty. You know Lefty. You got go- You gotta go to storage, man
You've gotta go. Hey, fruit punch, man. You're all right, I guess, but uh this ball pit. Yeah, you know what? Something about this ball pit
Don't rub me right. What about this one? Maybe I shouldn't have bought the extremely cheap things- alright. Well that guy's okay
I'm not gonna get rid of him. Oh
Yeah, there we go. Risk nice eleven. That's tolerable
why've i done this to myself. why have I done this to myself? I don't think it's gonna help at all is it
[nose honk!]
[ad starts playing] no
[Dilapidated springtrap jumpscare] Ah! wahaha oh my God...
Dilapidated springtrap: That was easier than i thought it would be.
Jeez, you don't need to rub it in my face like that. Okay, so I'm missing a key...
mechanic fundamental here obviously.
I'm missing a key game mechanic fundamental 'cuz I'm dying quicker and quicker. Light a ..? Yes, [buys]
yes, yes, yes yes, ah.
Marked down? that doesn't seem good. Uh Pan Stan. You know Pan Stan
I don't think anything's hiding in you, but I don't- I'm not too into it. Just not into it- gonna buy this,
gonna buy these
Fruity maze, midnight motorists. Oh look at these things. Yes!
Marked down? no.. *shakes head* [laughs]
No. Ooh traffic light? Oh you? Condition terrible? [nervous laughter]
Ah, you know what? maybe not, maybe not.
you- yeah- okay- alright-
Okay, maybe I should just never buy the horrible ones. I should probably just never all the liability risk ones,
You know them doesn't seem good you get- get- get outta here
just get out take one balloooon
Thats sad that's not fun...
Midnight motorcade! Alright, you get out of here. *laughs*
You- you get out Robo– Robo machine!
Safety is my number one priority. You oh no, not you, not you, not you. know you there is no risk 'cuz we got Number One Cage!
And we got...
Hey! Good.
Yes.
The gang's all here! *laughter*
we got Pigster, Ned Fred, Mr. Hippo and...
Number One Cage!
Tiny crate cramblem.
Yayyyy, and light- light-
stolen light lambleden!
All right, I still don't think this is gonna help me at all. I still think I'm boned.
Very extremely boned...
Finished!. We go now.
I'm still gonna die.
[ventilation turns on]
I'm doomed, i'm doomed! [ad starts to play] No! NOOOO! I'm doomed!
Baby: I heard your call...
No you didn't!
You didn't hear nothing. Actually it was all actually a l– A lot of nothing surprisingly. Shockingly. It was nothing.
Amazingly. A whole lot of nothing. Weirdly enough so much not– Uh, uh- so much nothing. [ventilation turns off] You know?
Turns out...
Turns out, just a lot of nothin'.
Just like an oscillating fan myself.
Uh-oh, here comes the theories im just an oscillating fan.
[ad plays] NUP! mmmmmm
Well this is a lot of noise.
[Molten Freddy jumpscare] AAAHH! C'mon i have no idea, i have no idea.
[Molten Freddy]: "One biiiig happy family!"
I mean I'm getting closer to the truth, but I-I still- Oh my God. This is difficult!
Oh man why am I salvaging these things? Why am I bothering? Why?
[sighs] Why do I try?
[Dilapidated springtrap jumpscare] oh
Dilapidated springtrap: I always come back...
Okay, i think- I think what it is is like the audio has a sphere of influence
That's what I'm seeing from that, so the audio needs to be, if they're in that right area,
They need to hear it to be able to move it, if I just put it in the corner,
it's not gonna do any good. I gotta like lead them around,
away. If that is the case you know what I'm saying?
That's what I gotta do.
[Lefty Jumpscare] Ohhhhh...
[Dilapidated springtrap Jumpscare] gah
Scrapped Springtrap: "That was easier than i thought it would be"
[Molten Freddy Jumpscare] Ahhh...
It's so hard! [Molten Freddy: Suprise!]
It's so hard! oh my God...
This is better than i've done in a while.
[Power and ventilation resumes]
This is a lot of very cautious moves.
Stopping after every one-
Ooh.
Oh no.. are they on both sides?
*mutters quietly* Oh no...
EEE!
*mutters quietly* Oh come on.
Scrap Baby: I heard your call. Mark: No...
What- i don't know what to do!
[Power and ventilation resumes]
Ah c'mon, c'mon, c'mon!
[Power and ventilation shuts off] I heard that...
[Power and ventilation resumes]
C'mon c'mon c'mon...
One more thing, just one more..
Dilapidated Springtrap: "You may not recognize me at first, but I assure you it's still me."
[Power and ventilation once again resumes]
Oh oh, oh- no no no no no no no not now..
Was that.. moving out?
Ok. [Power and ventilation resumes again]
Last one, last one, last one!
I'M OUT! I'M OUT! I'M OUT!!! OH MY GOOOD!! GAAAAAHH!
It's so stressful! it's so stressful.
It's so stressful, but I'm learning with my brain hole.
Casette player: Before you is an animatronic found in the back alley.
We are unsure of its origins. Mark: Uh huh...
Casette player continues: ...It is your job to complete the maintenance checklist before claiming it as salvaged. Or, if you choose to;
you can throw it back into the alley where you found it and forfeit payment. Please make your choice now.
Ugh..
UUMM..
UUHH..
euuuhh?
aaAAAh?
I don't like yooou!!!
YOU'RE NO PAN PETE!!!
YOU'RE NO PICKLE PETER!!!
You're no pickle Piper Peter mr. Winkie Man!
*mutters* I don't like you.
I'm going a little crazy. Okay. I'll throw you back.
Narrator:  Don't forget Saturday. You want them all to be in one place.
whaaaaaaaa- Umm,
I don't know if I want that. I don't think I want that,  no one turned away? Hell Yeah. Oh hell yeah. oh yayyy
Lawsuits?
Yaaaa! [laughter]
How did my last lawsuits go? Probably not good.
Ugghhhh... Okay, alright, wait hang on..
Oh, this is coma girl. You know what, I'm just gonna settle. I'ma settle that's all about– Hey we won!
Hell yeah! ahahahahaha
Alright we'll settle this one, and now that'll be it. That'll be it because- whoa!
Nellie welly welly welly. Okay, so who's inside? What's the new sponsor?
Lally's Lollies! Lally's lollies? Look at Lally! have a lolly good time with Lally's Lollies.
[laughter]
uhh- alright- ok i'll go for it
I'mma put- I wanna put Lefty back up there. (NO, YOU- ah crap.)
Lefty you– just the way you move, I just don't like it, I don't like it at all. Actually so- (THEN TAKE IT OFF!)
[laugher slowly fades to crying]
Alright so anyway, I'm all done for this episode.
Thank you everybody so much for watching. I'm getting better at this, but I can see how this is getting impossibly hard.
But, I'm getting better at it. So that's good. So thank you everybody so much for watching,
Let me know what you think down the comments below and as always I will see you in the next video!
buh-bye!
[Music]